that's funny as [__] like that multiple
times and it's very odd yeah I don't
know why we feel like we have to but we
just do it anyways yeah so I look at
other like fat people that eat and I'm
like [__] pig as I mean my [__]
filet fish I can't believe you're eating
that stuff
when did you get it though it looks
fresh it looks good
in five four three two oh yeah ring them
in dude bring them in bro everybody go
get it how many times have you been on
this podcast I don't know who does the
intro
interrupted it
in five four three two one welcome
everybody to a new episode of The Genius
brain podcast okay
sorry I can't you just can't help what
do you want to say I want to say before
I say say anything I just like I really
appreciate
go go
okay this is a real thing I was talking
to Magic that I was like it is really
cool that
um I'm on your podcast
because I want you I know I've said this
before but seriously because of the
thing is
um because you're Asian yeah you know
what I mean
dude
powder in your head and then whoever
doesn't die comes out but you get it
though hey dude you're the Asian all
right yeah I mean so it is nice I don't
want to say that you're the Asian yeah
you thought I was bullshitting I know I
thought you were [__] he has trust
issues because they're like oh yeah like
I thought you were bullshitting too we
were kicking it yeah this is funny I was
like I recommend you to David and he's
like oh yeah and then he was like my
podcast is like [__] I don't care
about the thing it's just but he's he
was a long time like honestly this is
gay dude
Jason's actually out of the closet yet
yeah and what's the problem that's okay
yeah I want to know do you get because
your your therapist diagnosed you with
uh autism do you do you get a handicap
thing do you get one of those blue
things or no I'm gonna try to get one
get one yeah it's good parking yeah and
uh people give you the benefit of the
doubt people don't even need the parking
placard you just walk out and say hi and
they know hi my name is Jesse
Lego yes you can go first Jason I do
have to say that yeah you do I know why
did you think that you that I would
invite you to my podcast he thought I
was gonna backstab him or something
what'd you think yeah and you know how
and and this is another thing too and
this is an honest thing it's really nice
to be on your podcast it is but the
thing is this sometimes I go hey I just
want to do a goofy good time because I
was I was like oh it's even cool it's
cool to hang to and be uh do I mean like
be a person and not have a weird thing
but it is cool to be do you know what I
mean I have no idea what you just said
Cass has been going for three minutes
and I don't know what the [__] he said
they get it so because the producer has
met Jason once and she's like okay like
a real person I don't know what Jason
said but I know that he meant it from
deep down in his house
whatever he said there was a lot of
passion there I don't know what it is
but he meant that [__] a lot so CTE but
you're not a fighter dude wasn't crazy
you have it don't worry I appreciate
your sincerity man yeah I don't know
what he said but I appreciate your
sincerity yeah
what do you try to communicate but you
don't know I think something good
from what I from what I'm assuming it's
a good sounds like something yeah it's
just sometimes because you know
sometimes it is weird to be like oh man
because um you are the Asian thing right
you're the Asian thing dude you know
what I mean you're the big Asian penis
Asian eyebrows
shiny face big potato tiny face
yeah you know yourself
[Laughter]
I will say this though right
we'll book them on this podcast they do
have to understand I am not universally
loved by most people like half people
really [__] with me the other half
[__] hates me yeah but that's the
that's the authenticity and that's what
I want to do and I think that's what all
Comics want to do is to be authentic
yeah and I really do take that page off
of Just Comics you know what I mean
because I started in stand up yeah and I
feel like even if people get butt hurt
people you know talk [__] or whatever at
least it's said it is put out there you
know what I'm saying but now it's like
if people come on this podcast they have
this fear of like oh what's he gonna ask
me was it was like well if you're not
comfortable being yourself or expressing
your thoughts then maybe you shouldn't
come on this podcast you know what I'm
saying sure or like if I dislike
something that somebody does I'll speak
I'll say I'm not like trying to take
them down I'm just like oh that's
[__] weird and they're like Well
why'd you have to do that I'm like well
why not but a lot of the times it's not
from hate it's just an opinion it's an
opinion it's observation yeah yeah you
know so but people act like in the
regular world people don't do that
that's normal yeah and so like I feel
like in this space everybody wants to
feel like they have to be protected by
others I think it's just because of the
industry yes the industry you don't
you're not supposed to be negative yeah
it's like I have no responsibility to
you as a person at all like you're in
the entertainment space you create art
your art supposed to be judged no matter
what right and like look I even this
right like I went on um um
the fighter and the kid right and then
when we did the whole Brenda shopping I
asked them like hey like what do you
feel about putting up like a bad special
that people didn't like you said that
yes because that's true
was this before or after Gringo poppy
was it Gringo poppy no it was before it
was the first one right and I was like
people didn't like it right and it
arguably wasn't that good yeah it was
something along those lines it was like
I boarded it nicely right and basically
what I wanted to get about was like not
to like [__] on him but it's like I
wanted to know
how does that feel you know what I'm
saying like how does it feel to produce
a big piece of [__] dude
how does it feel to try your best and
flop
right in your face
what I basically wanted to get was like
and that's a real good question in my
personal opinion because it's not like
how does it feel like when you read
through the comments it's glowing
reviews right but this is his like first
big special so I'm curious to like how
do you overcome this and what do you do
with this right and then like people
were like dude you [__] ripped on I
was like I didn't even do that I'm
actually just curious because that's a
huge fear of any comic to put out a
special and then for people to not
receive it the way that you want it to
yeah and so when I did that people were
shocked I'm like that shouldn't even be
shocking like that's a normal thing to
ask somebody right because it's not
Brenda Shop's not stupid he knows he
knows people didn't like it right so
it's like for me as I listened to the
fighter and the kid when it was him and
just it's just him and um yeah so I I
was kind of curious and I genuinely
wanted to know so people were like dude
I can't believe he said that to his face
I'm like but that's not even a burn yeah
I think in today's world people think
like because it's just a real question
but if it's like at all it's not even
confrontational it's just something
that's like a dis not a disagreement
even it's just like uh people are so
like beat around the bush or [__] if
you're direct about something people are
like oh he's burnt he's roasting him
it's not a roast it's just like this is
a direct maybe a little uncomfortable
but it's like it's just some real ass
[__] to ask somebody you know it doesn't
necessarily mean yeah like you know to
defend him as well too by the way like I
read comments about him what people say
yo his [__] he's the worst stand-up
comic ever I was like I don't think
you've been to comedy clubs right like
he is nowhere near the [__] worst
right he's actually actually not even
that bad like he's okay I I think or
and I thought about this a lot just
because I've seen so much hate go
towards him I'm like what is it that
people hate about him so much because I
couldn't figure it out like I get why
you don't like his stand-up but for
people to go out of their way and create
individual channels to go and hurt him
take money out of his pocket when he has
a family and kids yeah I until this day
I will still not condone and I don't
understand it like there's specific
dedicated channels that watch him
religiously just so they could create
content off of him yeah to feed the fan
base that hates him which I don't
understand why I mean look it's YouTube
you do whatever the [__] you want like
I'll even defend that person who does it
because you can do whatever I just I
can't wrap my head around it yeah but
then I did I started to kind of like
read the comments and see like okay let
me just dig into why people hate him so
much right and hate is a very strong
word let's just say dislike and I think
what it is is that people tend to want
to [__] on people who feel like they
don't deserve what they have right so he
got kind of catapulted to his area
because he's connected with Joe Rogan
and a few other comics
and I don't think and I thought to
myself at that point like that's not
even a problem either why is that such a
big issue everybody has that we're a
homie helps them out right right and
then I started reading other things and
started watching stuff I'm like oh I can
see why people may not like him so much
is because it's the way that he doesn't
know how to make fun of himself and he
also doesn't know how to roll with the
punches so instead of when people like
rip into them and they say all this
stuff he doesn't really laugh about it
he tries to defend himself which is I
think it's a very bad thing to do you
know what I mean as a comic you got to
make jokes out of everything when people
[__] [__] on you when people like
when I talk about comments or stuff my
first initial thing is to bring you up
because I have content now like it's not
like let me defend myself because this
person's wrong it's like how do I make
this funny you know how do I create
content I don't think Brendan shop does
that he goes you don't [__] know what
you're doing I'm the Standing comic I
get I'm co-signed by Joe Rogan if I
wasn't good then all these Comics
wouldn't be around me it's like that's
not the angle you should take and I
think that was the start to everybody
[__] on it and it took me a while to
figure this out because I just didn't
understand stand like why do people hate
this guy you know that's a very deep and
good analysis man I have too much time
on my hand when I'm [__] making my
tomatoes grow yeah that makes sense I'm
thinking about Brandon yeah just
thinking about Brandon what do people
hate Brennan good strategy because like
honestly like I would read stuff and I
see people [__] on him and I would get
my feelings hurt for him because I get a
lot of bad comments too but nothing to
his experience no they're like they're
like actively trying to take him down
yeah I mean like they're actively like
yeah it's a different kind of of uh
aggression yeah because it can't just be
like he's oh he's just not a funny comic
I think it's the way that he Joe the
angle in which he chose right which is
like I'm above this I don't read
comments I don't give a [__] what people
think that's a bad angle right and then
he try to shift it into I'm soft and I'm
sensitive so I that's why I don't read
comments just like well which one is it
you have to be consistent with the [__]
that you do I like if I was Brendan's
like PR team I would have told him like
Hey You Gotta make this funny you have
to you're the comic so if somebody goes
Brenda's a [__] habitual liar you
gotta lean into it you have to yeah I
mean that would be so funny it would be
so [__] funny right then crazy [__]
because I would just keep lying even
more yeah right you know what I'm saying
as well yeah you might as well you just
can't you know what I'm saying like oh
they start bringing up facts like oh
Brendan said this and this but what
about this and you're like dude my
[__] what are you talking about dude
I've had eight seven times and I beat it
yeah yeah right you know just like how
good would that be that'd be so fun yeah
you know and I I think like if he does
that even now he could turn the tide
like that yeah right I mean there's a
lot that's happened the Bobby Lee [__]
didn't help him out oh the Bobby Lee oh
that was really bad that's where he
really took a hit that's right we talked
about it I actually forgot about that
yeah that was a big hit yeah you're
pretty much [__] man my bad
cheers my bad speaking of bad reputation
dude uh [__] uh lizzo
did you guys hear that [__] yeah so it's
what the [__] is going on okay tell me
what's going on I'm breaking down I I
read this [__] before I came here
because honestly
I really don't [__] care yeah right
but because it's such a Hot Topic and
listen I have been somebody who is
adamantly defended lizzo only because I
felt like a lot of people were just
coming at her for just being fat like
all right she's fat so the [__] what I
don't want that feels like I see myself
in her okay if she ate me because I'm
kidding oh God damn it I'm going to hell
but she would I would adamantly
Defenders like yo let this girl [__]
live you know what I'm saying like she's
making music she's a big girl but then
people would always make comments about
like well if you were truly healthy who
the [__] cares He makes music yeah you
know what I mean like leave that [__]
aside and so a lot of people would like
Champion her and saying like oh you're
you're the spokesperson for for a
[__] big women and so this is the way
that she had this is honestly her big
fan base is like her movement of body
positivity so the lawsuit is a it's
compiled of multiple things like it's
based on sexual harassment so they were
saying that uh I forgot let's just say
it was in Atlanta no it was in Amsterdam
I'm sorry
uh he they're stating that she forced
them to do stuff that was very
uncomfortable sexually like they took
she took them forced them to take uh to
go to a strip club
and there was a point where some
um stripper had a banana coming out of
the pants and they she forced them to
eat it
um I'm not sure if this part is true but
I read this where she basically said
like if you don't do this you're fired
along those type of lines okay you know
what I mean and then she would really
kill them for other things she would
make fat shaming comments
to her dancers and remember she's the
body positivity girl
especially just calm fat and stuff is
that because the dancers or if they're
like out of shape or whatever and the
lawsuit doesn't just entail a lizzo it
it also includes the the main person who
choreographed the dances and so they are
also saying that she would do things
that were
um inappropriate in a work setting in
terms of a religious conversations like
they would she would talk about uh ask
people if they were virgins uh talk
about Christianity and push it on them
and there was like a dancer who spoke
about that they were a virgin and they
shoot on a publication said that she was
aversion to other people and she wasn't
comfortable and so like it's it's a
weird weird thing that's going on and
lizzle obviously came out and was like
this is absolutely not true like this is
and what they're alluding to was like
it's funny that the three people that
are
um suing us right now were actually
reprimanded not too long ago because of
their like sexual misconduct or it
wasn't sexual misconduct but it was
inappropriate behavior is what they said
so those three were actually uh in
trouble for acting inappropriately and
then now these three people are suing
lizzo okay so it's just weird thing so
like the reason why it's blowing up is
because she's a body positive to be
clean but she's being sued for fat
shaming that's the headline I saw yeah
so fat shames other fatties
what you doing eating that [__] yeah but
how do you fashion somebody when they're
yeah but I think there's no way she did
it seriously well who knows what
happened I mean wait wait so what the
three people they they got in trouble
for what sexual misconduct today it
wasn't sexual misconi was inappropriate
behavior what were they would they do
don't know but little hasn't said what
it was but um that's basically what
they're saying they're suing her see
this is difficult to because well first
of all we don't know exactly what
happened right number one no one really
knows what's going on we just have
accusations
two uh
the entertainment world is weird like
it's not you're not in an office you
know what I mean the conversations are
going to happen like even the fact that
you guys took a work trip to a strip
club like that's that's normal in
entertainment exactly like that's like
an entertainment World type thing you
would never do that if you're working at
[__] Kinkos you know I mean at FedEx
hey guys let's go to [__] strip club
and eat a banana out of somebody's ass
you know what I mean like that would
never happen but this is a good time
like like notice that no one complained
like hey she took us to a strip club on
a work meeting right it's like it's like
oh no I had to eat the banana out of the
dude's ass no that's right
club's a problem it's like no I went
there and then I had a banana yeah right
no issue with the strip club to begin
with so the entertainment world is weird
to start right with the rules so who
knows but also what did did she go like
hey uh if you don't eat eat the banana
you're gonna get fired or or she's what
they're alluding to yeah but or did she
go if you don't eat the banana you know
oh she said it yeah yeah it could be a
joke yeah I mean who who knows who knows
eat that banana oh you fired [__]
because I hear a lot of people say [__]
like that and it's on in fact honestly I
could picture her saying that but like
it could be in like a joking type way
yeah that's the thing too we'll keep you
serious when people read these headlines
right you actually don't know what's
going on everything is alleged right and
we've you know we've we've like I've
been in situations too where like this
criminal employees be making up [__]
[__] sure like they say like it's yeah
it's what happened but they twist like
20 of it and it's like no that's not how
it was said and that's not how it was
done and that's not how you behaved it
was just after the fact because they
want to look like a saint that they
twist everything around right so now
it's a matter of who in that dance
company is going to back up the other
person or what because this is where
like you'll never really know the truth
yeah right always going to be a he said
she said everything right for me I find
it I kind of see it like well what's the
context like you said right like okay
you're already at a strip club which is
already inappropriate right so you're
not mad that you went to a strip club
you're mad because it didn't go down the
way that you wanted it to right but it
felt so bad that because whenever you do
a thing people just believe the thing
most people they don't go let's look
into it they go oh yeah it's juicier to
be like oh lizzo's fat shaming people
yeah but most people's gonna believe
that they go oh this is a terrible
person I mean
which is also hilarious
as herself like that's funny as [__]
like that multiple times and it's very
odd yeah I don't know why we feel like
we have to but we just do it anyways
yeah so I look at other like fat people
that eat and I'm like [__] pig as I'm
eating my [__] filet-o fish
I can't believe you're eating that stuff
when did you get it though
fresh
yeah no but that's what I'm like when I
read what people say about lizzo and the
whole situation they talk about
allegations as if they were there and
it's facts you don't actually [__]
know and I see this in my personal
business work stuff too where you know
people be telling crazy stories about
them like that's funny because there's
12 other people there that say the exact
opposite that's what's so annoying about
today's world is everyone speaks on
certain subjects as if they're the ones
that know the things like for sure and
no one knows no one knows it almost
seems like if you say it first then
that's if you say first it has so much
power to draw people's attention and go
oh then the other person has to be so
you have no idea what you're talking
about [__] like you weren't there like
what the [__] and also read what I read
exactly and also her fans too who are
like turning who are like turning their
back on her right like these are also
the type of fans too that when she lost
a little weight because she was eating
healthier they [__] went in on her
they were like Oh I thought you were the
body positivity Queen why are you
[__] trying to lose weight it's like
there's like she can't do anything it's
like the people that are mad at Adele
Adele lost the gang of weight he got got
pretty fine and then it was like [__]
[__] they're all mad that she lost
weight
yeah she's healthy she's healthier dude
Billy eilish she went to the Met Gala
and she was dressed you know in her Met
Gala outfit and you know Billy eilish
who's known to be a tomboy right with
gazangas she pulled out the tatas yeah
Billy is pretty as [__] talented as
[__] hell too the whole [__]
package the shebang Goofy and weird as
[__] but listen
ERS
they're amazing they came out of nowhere
literally literally came out of nowhere
right
I just had to say that yes well babalues
chimichangas sweater puppies yeah
sweater puppies duffels yeah titties
with nibbles on it there you go okay all
right oh this is it anatomically what it
was the autistic guy speaks hey man hey
dude sorry that was a rude hammocks so
we have um this lady
so Billy ice comes out and she's just
very beautifully right people went in on
this poor girl they're like you're
[__] oh oh now you're trying to be
all this this and that like you're
[__] your sellout haters she's like
what the [__] like I'm at the Met Gala
you know what I mean like let me just be
myself yeah [__] off like I don't
understand like fan bases like that that
they have where they kind of they assume
what these people are without even
knowing who they are right and also too
if she wants to lose weight let her
whatever vibe that she's on whether
she's Big Skinny or small let her do
what she wants yeah be like feminine and
also like tomboy at the same time
exactly yeah you know what I'm saying
like maybe someday she wants to wear
baggy clothes other times she wants the
sweater puppies out yeah yeah I'm not
complaining yeah I'm not downloading
this footage yeah right
it's not on my phone right now in my
YouTube save videos I didn't put my hand
on my penis in the bathroom of the
studio podcast yeah yeah
I'm not in the shower for an extra 10
minutes yeah
water gets cold water gets a little cold
shower so long
and jerking off in here for too long let
me say something you ever masturbating
during a hot shower and you get
light-headed and you pass out yeah yeah
I know yeah I know yeah I know these
things yeah I know you guys know you
know what's up Jason nuts yeah you know
I don't know if I know
they're idiots dude these people are
[__] morons like dude who gives a
[__] you just don't know what's going on
in these like celebrity lives either
right like I just I never believe
anything that I read right now I only
talk about subjects like if we're on
this podcast I only talk about what
could be but it's not you never know
definitely and also now there's like Ai
and like the voice thing the Deep fake
thing like I feel like in like you know
a couple of years people just gonna be
making up stuff oh for sure that's gonna
happen dude because it's so real videos
have you seen like deep fake porn I
haven't seen it is it good I've I I
haven't but yeah I heard it
and it's not okay yeah now have I seen
it absolutely not
but I came a lot but there's a there are
okay let's just say this there are
people that I wish when I was younger
that I wish I knew what they looked like
naked Hillary Clinton you could do
Hillary Clinton
Pelosi was the first one Nancy Pelosi
yeah you want to talk about some Billy
eilish's Pelosi yeah yeah she's a
fantastic dude as well but like that
whole deep fake thing I remember like
you know when for everybody's like oh
that's [__] dope because now you
don't gotta wait for like them to do a
naked scene but then one celebrity I
forgot who it was it's like dude that's
still my likeness and the idea that
somebody's using me as like jack off
material yeah okay [__]
it like it [__] with my head well the
thing is if somebody wants to jack off
to you they're already doing you're not
gonna stop them yeah
you're not going to they'll just look at
your Instagram they'll jerk off they'll
see you in the street and remember it
jerk off at home okay let me tell you
specifically in my 20s I would do
drive-by lookings and I'm like got it
and I'll just walk around
you say it out loud got it I don't even
know what like what's that you don't
need to know don't worry about it it
goes up to a wall if it's close
and I have an imagination I don't need
porn at all yeah I just see people's
faces that's what I'm saying you don't
even know people have been doing that
forever yeah people do that forever even
before the internet someone wants to
jerk off to you they're gonna jerk off
to you yeah man when I was when I was
just accept that I remember when I was
uh at my parents store and this is like
your Tina you would get like nrbs no
reason boners and I just remember like
some hot customers will walk through and
I was like [__] my dick is gonna get
hard for sure because I'm like 13 14
years old like anything would get it
hard like I would look at lip gloss and
I'm like whoa all right so I remember
this one customer came through and she
was 5 fine as [__] I was like whoa and
then my dick immediately damn hard as
[__] and I I kept on trying to think of
other things it didn't work so literally
in the middle of the store I had to go
to the bathroom I had to whack went off
and then come out wow because I couldn't
focus holy [__] like being a young
person and being horny is like the most
annoying thing on earth it causes you to
start dating people who have very thin
eyebrows it really does it's the
weirdest thing ever like I hated that as
a young person like always constantly
being horny and you can't just focus it
on anything at all the worst the worst
do you I feel like you're still like
that now dude no I mean I I dude I every
once in a while I gotta rub one out just
to focus you should hold it in just
holding a jack off for like two months I
didn't jack off for two months and it
actually felt really good oh no lately
I've been jerking off I gotta stop again
though I just want to like detox did you
did you feel better without jerking off
I actually did I felt more focused I was
like taking advantage of my time I was
more productive really yeah I felt how
many days in that you start feeling that
way
right away like right away yeah but like
the second day no probably like day
three or four I was like oh I'm filming
I'm like taking advantage of my time you
don't feel distracted you're not like I
feel like if you watch porn like it's
like somehow just jumbles your brain a
little bit you know what I mean I don't
know it's definitely not something you
should be consuming every day yeah you
know what I'm saying because I remember
recently I think I didn't masturbate for
like eight days right because I was
moving and [__] I was just exhausted all
the time but then towards like I
remember like day seven or eight
everything was making my dick hard yeah
right every you're ready to go genius
brain listeners this podcast is brought
to you by Mint mobile signing your life
away to a big wireless provider is kind
of like being trapped on a roller
coaster from Hell sure it looks fun at
first they probably threw in a free
phone but now you can't get off month
after month of insane bills and
unexpected Thrills like over riches and
surprise fees if that sounds like your
current big Wireless plan it's time to
get off the ride with mint mobile for a
limited time Wireless plans for mint
mobile are just 15 a month that's
unlimited talk text and data for just 15
a month mint mobile is here to rescue
you with premium Wireless plans for just
15 bucks a month my friends say bye bye
to your big Wireless plans jaw dropping
monthly bills and an unexpected overages
to get your new Unlimited Wireless plan
for just 15 bucks a month and get the
plan shipped to your door for free go to
mintmobile.com genius15 that's
mintmobile.com genius15 cut your
wireless bill to 15 bucks a month at
mintmobile.com genius15. and I I prefer
being older now because now I feel like
hormonally I'm a lot more balanced yeah
I mean like I don't have to when you're
when you're a young person
sex is like the biggest motivating
factor for everything is the reason why
you do better in school is the reason
why you lose weight is the reason why
you get fit you get buff all this other
[__] like I knew a dude like I know guys
who are like hardened Affiliated gang
members that dropped being thugs simply
because of a girl um yeah I mean yeah
like yeah you know what
I'm not [__] you anymore if you
continue to gang bang I'm not getting me
anymore
and the rest is history they join ivy
league College they're [__]
accountant [__] nuts sure like I know
guys who have converted to Christianity
because the girl that they like went to
a church that's wild and she's like you
need to love God as much as I love God
yes and the next level commitment and
next thing you know you just see guns
fall out of their pockets
they just fall to the floor and the
[__] bullets fall out everywhere I
don't need any of this like I know
pastors that had happened to it like
like there's like one of the most
popular thing in Korean churches is that
you always meet a pastor that used to be
a gangbanger all the [__] time with
it and the same story why'd you stop I
met a girl and the girl's the one that
changes them immediately she goes for
sure I can't do this if you keep
continuing this lifestyle
I'm a pastor and they immediately
changed well women definitely make men
grow up 100 it's a good deal 100 100
because if you're I mean unless you're
dating unless you're just dating some
crazy chick like that Filipino trick or
whatever but other than that you're
gonna you're gonna say a [__] numb
nuts but if you're dating a respectable
lady uh there's a certain standard that
she's not gonna put up with so you got
to grow up you know yeah I feel like I
grew up a lot you know ever since I've
been with my lady like we we she kind of
forced me to grow up in ways that I
didn't think I had to because like when
you're on your own and like I'm very
hyper independent right even like in the
first five years of a relationship we
never conferred with each other about
anything it was just like you do your
own thing I do my own thing and when we
come together we're a couple and that's
how we lived for like five years and
then when we moved in together it was
like a shocking thing for both of us
because we had to figure out a lot of
stuff that we hated about each other
that we didn't know about it's like oh
this is unacceptable I [__] hate this
I [__] hate this and I've we talked
about it too when she came on here when
you go into the specific details because
you know she doesn't feel comfortable
but we were going to split before we
moved in it was like we're done you know
and then we figured it out through like
couples therapy and a lot of stuff on
her side that she had to change that oh
like there that's right your fault
it was 80 her fall 20 mine 90 her fault
ten percent ninety five
98 291
991 100
but there are things that she kind of
realized through like therapy of like
projection like oh there are things that
I'm unhappy about myself that I'm
putting on to you that's not your fault
another things that I had to change and
this stuff wouldn't happen unless it was
because of her right so I really feel
like I say this now and we always joke
about it but she leaves me I'm [__]
yeah like we're at we're actually at a
really good place in our relationship
which is [__] odd do you feel like do
you feel like um
because when you did the separate thing
hyper independent because you have a lot
of guards before because you know
um nobody loved you
hold on let me hit it no no we loved you
and then you go I'm gonna love myself
and then
no this is from good intention though
there's no good intent in that at all
and then I'm on board yeah okay because
nobody loves you and then what is wrong
with you no no because I feel like that
too why nobody okay something Buddy
some people bad dude
some people body love you some people
dance
I like some people's body yeah I like
everybody's a good one flows some people
like some people are in the body love
you continue your thought yeah and then
um and then after
you after like grinding with a person
who has a really kind heart
which is your wife now and uh but after
you lay your guard down and now that you
you you you that really the hyper
Independence is gone now and now you
depend on her like emotionally like so
for me what it was was the a lot along
the lines of why it was hard for me to
get connected to people romantically and
even like let's say on a parental level
right like my parents it was hard for me
to get close to aside from all the other
[__] that being [__] it's like
well I think what a lot of people don't
realize is that some people who are
afraid of commitment aren't so much
afraid of commitment because like
they're afraid that this part is going
to be an [__] or try not to be evil
is because you're afraid to fall in love
with somebody because the idea that that
person could love and hurt you so like
you people sometimes don't get attached
to people because they're like oh one
day I realize this person might die and
I might be left alone so I'd rather be
alone right now so I don't have to
experience that in the future and I had
that yeah that makes sense I didn't want
to get close to my parents or my mom
every time I felt I got closer to my
parents I started to realize the the
finite idea of what life is yeah like my
parents one they won't be around there's
been times where I'll be able to call my
mom and she won't pick up yeah so don't
love them at all exactly
yeah no I get it yeah yeah
appreciative and I would self-sabotage a
lot of [__] it's like oh like I don't
like this about you I'm done with you
you know what I mean yeah but really
what it was like I like too much about
you yeah and you're actually probably
even too good for me and I don't want to
mess up this good thing so let me just
destroy this ahead of time before I can
go [__] it up later right yeah totally
yeah and so like with the weird with her
even like later on in the relationship I
started to realize like I don't want to
share things with her I don't want to
say things with her say these things
because I feel like number one is too
vulnerable and number two the more I
start to love her even more I start
becoming very cognizant that one day
like she might not be around yeah but
that's the assume that for some reason
in my scenario I always outlive her but
like she's always dying before me yeah I
look at it I'm like so when you die
before me nah dude God's Gonna punish us
man we're gonna go first yeah 100 to
punish us they're gonna [__] go first
dude you already know it and I'm gonna
just be sitting here crying every
[__] day yeah and like that reality
when it hits you becomes a very dark
reality yeah for other people they kind
of want to fall in love because they
want they're very present in the now and
they go I love this feeling I want it to
last forever for me it's like okay if I
get closer to this person what happens
when they die when they leave me
yeah like this is [__] sad as [__]
and you feel like these small moments
like for example when your dog dies like
if you had a dog for like 10 14 years
and all of a sudden they're gone the
next day it's like [__] I never want a
dog again right bro every day I think
about my dog dying just so that you
could appreciate it more
I'm not not your wife
she's gonna live for a long time this is
my dog dogs don't like when they love
you they [__] love you dude like
sometimes when I look at my dog like the
dog just looks up at me like I'm the
[__] dopest [__] on Earth that's
awesome and like damn what the [__] is
wrong with you yeah what's wrong with
you like sometimes I just punch you in
your sleep because you make me mad I'm
[__] Petty dude my dog would like
wake me up at 5am in the morning because
it wants to play and so I would get so
[__] mad but whenever the dog's
sleeping peacefully I would wake it up
I'm like wake up
how do you [__] like it dude
I don't care how do you feel now these
wake up if they're happy as [__] yeah
damn it it didn't work it did a [__]
Warfare yeah they enjoy the [__] [__]
it's so whack
but I think that's why people people
love their dogs because they they only
live like 10 to 15 years because if they
live like 200 years I would take it for
granted a hundred percent again eat it
oh yeah yeah every day I'm gonna [__]
pick up your [__] yeah but 10 yeah 10 15
years that's why we love them so much
it's like nobody [__] like turtles
dude they live too long they live like a
hundred years what the [__] and they
smell like goo
yeah just like bad Google why does goo
smell like would think about goo what
color is it put your what color is goo
in your in your hair okay it's in
between green and brown mine's purple oh
wow that's a beautiful blue yeah
some people's body
I smell like some people's body yeah you
know hey Giuseppe every time you come in
a room or you smell like some people's
body you smell something
because you smell like a ghoul dude my
so my buddy's wife is a veterinarian
they have so she keeps bringing [__]
animals home dude it's like Dr
Doolittle's house they have like three
dogs two cats oh the [__] bearded
dragon a couple lizards a [__]
tortoise dude a tortoise with three legs
they're all injured by the way the dog
has one eye tortoise has three legs is
this person white no she's uh Filipino
what the [__] guys white he's white
she's Filipino she she uh the tortoise
has three legs I didn't know they could
do this but they could do a surgery
where they put a wheel on the tortoise
like they can attach a wheel to the
missing and I was like do that [__]
right now get that Mad Max ass
[Music]
that [__] animal sucks though it's
just a boring ass like what the [__] is
this stupid again it only comes out for
lettuce yeah do you just see all I see I
see the tortoises and like is this my
friend Henry and
editors yeah my dad dad died of cancer
but Henry's still around and Henry
doesn't give a [__] about you no it
doesn't you have to spray water in the
hole and then you bring a [__] piece
of bell pepper and it just comes out
like and it looks like my [__]
Grandpa it always looks like a 100 year
old Asian man
but you know what the the way they [__]
the sound that they make when they [__]
is
yeah
it's a nice sound it's nice oh no have
you seen a [__] tortoise dick is
gross I'm not interested it doesn't look
like it just looks like a pile of
intestines on the floor it's [__]
disgusting that's how you sound when
you're upset yeah but I make it sound
nice when you come
it's [__] weird as [__]
yeah but
let me tell you something
the other day like uh so I talked about
this on a solo podcast when I was doing
um when I was moving and [__] because I
didn't have time to do anything so I
just like at 12 a.m I would do a podcast
by myself which is very difficult by the
way oh yeah that was
so you guys heard about the island boys
thing right oh yeah
[__] big tongue [__] each other right
what is that so they're doing it for
only fans for money they're Brothers
they're brothers and they're making out
and they're making do they [__] each
other okay so here's the thing I want to
be surprised gross dude so they're
rebuttal to this like a couple weeks
after this whole debacle came out one of
the brothers says like you know what you
guys don't even [__] know
I'm actually I'm for real gay and then
I'm like you kissed your brother that's
not the problem yeah right the problem
isn't that you kissed another man the
man is your brother identical twin [__]
is he talking like that's how
fried their brain is yeah this fool like
sat around for hours devising [__] like
hey they don't even know I'm about to
Uno reverse their ass I'm gay and
everybody's like it's still incest yeah
that's [__] gnarly dude yeah that's
crazy these [__] are dumb as
[__] I cannot [__] believe that dude
let me ask you something do you have
your sisters though that'd be pretty
dope that would be pretty nice that'd be
pretty everyone would be like hey Alan
girl
yeah
[Music]
and I see some [__]
but whatever it's different
yeah it is different hey it's different
dude every everybody has that fantasy of
the twin sisters
three something when you were younger
not me now I don't have the libido and
also is like a lot of work I feel like
and it's like a lot of like Nuance
because it's what's the Nuance you've
done threesomes before I actually
haven't okay
a couple times but no but it's like but
there's too much to do it's like because
you have a threesome no oh but that's
what I'm saying even I would never have
the opportunity but if I did have that
video I would I just feel like it's
really uh you have to conduct yeah you
have to conduct and it's like I'm
already thinking too much with one
person and now I gotta think of two
persons
open your [__]
it's like The Bugs Bunny when he's the
conductor dude and he's like
yeah dude number one I have anxiety
issues
absolutely my anxieties you obviously
don't care because you ambushed me
I have issues with anxiety yeah there's
no [__] way that I could like figure
out how to have intercourse with two
other women yeah impossible really I
can't do it yeah me neither like what am
I doing it's like okay do I put the
finger in this one and then the penis in
this one yeah and then and how do I get
the Rhythm or does the other girl sit on
my face and then she hops on this it's a
lot of work a lot of work I think it's a
combination of all those things okay but
so much work yeah but you got to be like
we're not shooting guns like you're
[__] in the wild Yosemite
clear your arms
it's ever dude look at her doggy style
and he's like
hey guys so I'm I'm ready
yeah I don't know I don't think that's a
part of it no all right I think you
would just you just kind of you know
they they if they they obviously have to
hook up with each other too but you you
will overthink like because if you're
putting your penis in one and you're
like well I have trouble trying to make
her come ready and then what about the
other person I gotta make her come and
what is she doing I gotta keep her
occupied because she can't just be
watching if we're having threesome I
used to watch this Playboy TV show
called swingers have you guys seen that
show I've never seen it so it's
literally two couples that and I watched
this during college
it was two couples
uh or it was a couple that would come in
not two couples and it's a swinger event
where these people want to try swing
they never
Swang before swing
I don't know if that's the [__] term
but they never swonged right never swung
so never swunged ever in their life and
so they have like porn stars in this
room or like people who have swung
before yeah and they start doing sexual
games or whatever and these people are
hyped to swing and it's like oh wow an
orgy of like 20 people oh that's weird
and it's just the interesting and like
what you start to understand about like
the psychology is that some people want
to [__] but the other half of the people
that were on the show per episodic they
wanted to see their partner [__]
somebody they want to get cooked they
want to get cooked and mind you they're
also having sex too they're you get
they're getting fondled right the
professional term they're getting
fondled they're getting fandangled a
little bit too entangled and they're
watching and I'm like this is a very
interesting because this is a lot of
stimulation yeah like there was this one
guy
um he wanted to have sex with multiple
women at once and it was him just
getting fellatioed by like four women
okay and he's just having the time of
his [__] life and his wife is
watching him and she is getting smashed
from behind watching him getting
fellased and she's getting smashed she's
getting smashed by some other guy
God
is insane damn like when you watch the
show it's it doesn't turn me on it's
just like a social experiment swinger
[__] is weird but you can't even come
back from that imagine getting [__] by
some other dude watching your husband
getting fellatioed Yeah by four Dudes
like weird there's no you can't be doing
four like regular sex anymore no it's
it's there's no turning back yeah you
gotta go there you got to do a thing
like hey can we have sex and you do the
foreplay at home and now you gotta drive
to the thing yeah drive to some other
dude's house
104. you're gonna go like 30 minutes
down the road to come who used to be a
friend that his fantasy is getting
cucked oh man he would he said I
remember he said that [__] out loud and
the whole room you ever heard like I
said it out loud yeah record break like
everybody was like no we don't relate to
this at all yeah he's like hey guys you
guys are one I have fantasy and
everybody's like oh yeah what's that and
he's like I want to see my wife gets
[__] by another guy and everybody
stopped and we're like what the [__] are
you talking about dude
bring your wife over here dude
yeah like what guy dude I'm right here
dude bring that [__] up but that's like
his his fantasy that's weird she's not
down but yeah that's that's a weird
fantasy and for him though it's a weird
fantasy but he's he's definitely he's a
strange guy he's beta as [__] like she
calls she calls him like a [__] oh like
all that type of stuff and he just takes
it oh he probably loves it I've
literally seen like I've had dinner with
this couple before and she's just going
in on him calling him a bit he's just
like uncomfortably laughing in front of
everybody at the dinner because you're
like likes it I don't know if he likes
it like that oh man but it's weird like
watching the relationship Dynamic he
wants to watch his wife get piped yeah
weird like and he openly admits it like
there was a point
I'm [__] aroused man you're like hey
can you continue the story but then do
it ASMR Style
of his wife having sex with another
person as he watches that's gonna be
trauma right there's something weird
though but that doesn't make sense but
listen I met this Fool's dad and his
dad's also kind of a weirdo too that's
weird bro he told me that when he was a
kid he had the first memories he has of
his dad at a ball game is him bringing
binoculars so he could look at the
skirts up up the skirts of [__]
cheerleaders oh wow yes that's a [__]
pervert Yeah so he kind of inherited
some of that [__] a Peeping Tom yeah a
little bit like it's like it's a genetic
deformity from there because peeping Tom
at age of
13. he's he's definitely been caught
doing a lot of [__] weird [__] yeah
this guy's got issues a hundred percent
like he's he's done like very odd odd
things where like we had to call him out
on him like bro what the [__] are you
doing yeah but this is why this person's
a former friend like he I just can't
[__] with that type of [__] yeah you
know what I'm saying but like I don't
understand the idea of that but I know
that's like a huge category in
pornography is like cooking yeah and
that's like a term I only learned like a
few years back because I'm like why the
[__] would anybody enjoy that so
sometimes when I see like a title like
oh I'm gonna tell you you have a small
penis
yeah that's a thing like a bit a little
thing or whatever oh oh so like why
would I want there's people who are like
in high levels like in high power say
that to me oh look at this it's
microscopic
humiliated like they get off again
humiliated so a lot of dudes in high
positions of power that are so used to
bossing other people around oh my they
like being belittled so that's why they
get dominations just like like crushed
their balls called them [__] they're
losers they're not anything and it gets
them off because the next level of that
I've heard there was a cam girl that was
talking there's there's black male porn
have you heard of that so black male
porn so it's essentially in in the same
lines of this it's just a notched higher
so these guys will give these girls like
their bank account numbers like they're
checking and routing numbers they'll
give them like their their wives
blackmail yeah not bad I [__] her as
black male no no no no no no no
blackmail like like
yeah that's just like BBC [__] no no no
blackmail like they're blackmailing them
so they'll give these girls their
checking and routing number they'll give
them their wife's cell phone number and
they get off they want the girls to like
threaten them to like actually hit their
wife up or like hey I'm gonna take all
your money I'm gonna do this like and
like really have like their finger on
the button and sometimes actually do
certain [__] and these guys get off on
the fact that they're being like
yeah that's what they're into
that is [__] wild that is weird dude
I like having sex with my boxers on no
I'm getting on fire
that's even weirder dude what the [__]
kind of weird close her eyes don't you
[__] look at me yeah and then I also
get a blanket in between and I cut a
hole for the vagina that's the Christian
way to do it that is the Christian way
to be a homie that actually would [__]
with this boxers on I was like are you
Mormon not like what's wrong with you
dude oh he slide it to the side
oh the hole that's that's a different
thing so he would put it to the you know
the hole you're supposed to pee through
I've never been through the hole I've
never been through the holy size only on
accident I'm like I've like pulled my
pants on like my dick through the hole
for some reason like I don't know why
but he would purposely have sex through
the hole I know a dude his wife has
never seen him naked
and maybe smashes so he also has sex
through the dick hole
never and he's openly talked about it I
from what I remember on a few videos
that we've done but I'm not gonna say
his name just in case this is just a
private conversation I forgot to that uh
that I'm mixing up but the Wine's
talking now
possible taking over man yeah go crazy
that red blood but he has also never
farted in front of his wife and she's
never farted in front of him that's
weird and they never change clothes in
front of each other dude that that's my
that's my thing like I want you to fart
immediately
like on the first day because because
the thing I want to see you on a dating
app so bad because I want to see all
your cards because I want to be like is
this gonna because that's with my wife
the first date I'm like just fart and I
farted
on purpose I squeeze one I go okay
that was her first date yeah
I did that uh because I want to see all
your cards because if you hold it in for
two years how about you just talk to her
and ask her what her hobbies are you
idiot yeah everybody got Hobbies say the
thing do the Deep stuff don't do the
hobby thing hey Carrie I just want to
tell you this right now I'm enjoying
this date but I need to stiff it I need
you to fart okay I need a sniff if you
don't sniff it I don't know what you
have for lunch and if I don't know what
you have for lunch this ain't love
because
did she fart in front of you on the
first date no but accidentally she did
it on the second day and then I was like
I like it I didn't say that but we did
but I did I didn't do like you like the
engine machine
I don't get when people like hold the
thing for two years because it's like
then what else are you hiding like what
kind of other personalities you know
Bart right yeah Bart has never
ever heard Geo fart ever they've been
together for almost like two decades but
I I thought about that I've been with
girls who I like I never heard five like
how long have you been together my last
exercise was with her for a while never
heard a fart and then that Astro like
you you must fart like what she's like
I'll just go into the bathroom or
whatever okay but that's another thing
you don't have to because if you show
everything besides the fart that's nice
because you keep your femininity but
then if you the whole fart and also
don't show the rest of your personality
it's a weird thing like show me your
negative things like one time at least
and then hide it and then hide it yeah
or if you never fart and then but you
show me all your personality and we go
through life as partners and then you're
down for me but you never heard your ex
fart ever how long were you guys
together
couple years this is a couple years ever
you never even heard her like [__]
you know where it sounds like the island
conch yeah because you [__] farted in
the toilet no so I've never heard she
would go to the bathroom I know what
she's like pooping or whatever you know
but like I never actually heard a fart
and I would I'd be like yeah actually
never like why not and she's like I'll
just like go to the would you ever go
I'm gonna go take a [__]
I will be releasing a vlog
what the [__] what's in your household
right now yeah what's going on you do
that every time like you announce
something
it's time
here I'm gonna take a shotgun hey I I
think it's a family because my dad was
like that
he would announce that he would fart
yeah poop no no he would take a [__]
he'd go
it takes time to shoot hey Jason it's a
time for me to poopy I'm not sure that's
how your father sounds but I'm just
doing the racial impersonation of your
father hey Jason it's a time for me to
poop okay
that's [__] hilarious yeah I never
heard it but I mean she I asked her
about it she's like yeah fart but like
it's just another room or something yeah
because like what's going on actually I
never heard you fart she's like yeah
I'll go she's like I'm doing this to
preserve our relationship and our love
I mean I think she just wasn't gassy to
begin with really I feel like women are
in as gassy as women be gassy it's my
wife this lady be blasting them off dude
I'm talking about she sleeps and then if
I hear a trumpet I'm like I know who's
playing that instrument that's hilarious
yeah she's over here just [__]
warning the other crowd of the war's
coming
like what the [__] Steamboat like the
[__] is this from my YouTube video that
I'm watching at night or just you
[__] God damn dude when did she start
though so the first time I remember
hearing her fart was
we were this is what we were dating and
I still remember her outfit black
bottoms leopard top right and this was
on Valentine's Day and this is when we
were we decided to be serious I made her
a meal I Rose stated uh heirloom carrots
with a with a balsamic reduction and a
goat cheese like little thing
golden beets roasted early carrots all
this other [__] right and then I made a
uh
a little clam pasta with a little butter
a little see whatever one nice what I do
right holy [__] that's nice she's a
little lactose they didn't know that
[__] yeah right so she's sitting on my
lap we're about to make out and then she
blasts ones on my thigh she farted on
your thigh on my [__] thigh and I
died laughing that's hilarious I
couldn't stop laughing because she farts
and she doesn't even get in bed she just
goes oops
she's [__] hilarious and that's the
first time I heard a fart that's great
one time one night though like she
started farting so much I think she got
a little too comfortable and I literally
had to talk to her I was like hey this
no too much too much I need you to dial
it back yeah like now now I don't know
if a dick can be dry but my dick is dry
yeah
it's like a piece of chalk only in a
little bit yeah you know
two farts three farts okay yeah but
every time you walk by me and you just
[__] crop dust me yeah yeah yeah
every time you take a bite of your meal
and you [__] let one out let's relax
every time you brush your teeth last one
relax every time we go into the elevator
and you cough thinking you're covering
your fart I know that's so far coughs
don't sound like that she was doing it
too much and I remember I had a
conversation it's like listen
this is not working yeah yeah hold it
back up in the relationship baby a
little bit yeah there's a little too
much you're making me love you less
exactly and I had to let I had to reduce
my farts around her too because I was
definitely farting it up a lot there's a
quota
dude three is like again three three is
like you're push you're getting you're
getting a girl
per day is a really good limit two per
day that's very one in the morning one
at night because you could do one
accident
do I mean like if you did one on purpose
yeah okay that's your one yeah and you
could do another one yeah excuse
yourself walk outside yeah dude Mario is
so [__] cute two per day she went she
she like took it this is when we were
first started dating she pooped in the
bathroom
and she's not comfortable with me enough
like that yet right and I need to take a
piss but I don't know she pooped so I'm
about to go into the bathroom
from the distance I just hear this
[Music]
this [__] shoves me to the wall like
this
she's like I took a poopy she's like I'm
not ready for you to smell it yet I
busted up laughing so hard she could not
have me smell her [__] [__] yeah and
then now she still doesn't want me to
right but sometimes she forgets and I
walk in and I'm like did you [__] eat
a dead animal on the side of the road
what the [__] is this other people's
[__] smells gross dude it's like it's
just like ugh I think I smell my own
[__] and I hate myself oh really like I
want to fight myself oh well not me I go
my [__] is nice sometimes I I know it's
bad but I'm like it's mine so I'm like
when I eat Indian Food Doc the the
[__] shit's crazy I'm not sure if
it's because of the spices per se but I
don't handle spicy food very well and
Indian people can eat some spicy ass
[__] food yo every now and then I'll
be sending him videos of like Indian
Street Food
and look I love Indian food I will say
this I personally love Indian food a lot
too right and I want all of like the
Indian homies who have subscribed to
this page to confirm this or deny it
I sometimes watch Indian Street food
just so I could be like who the [__] is
eating this because this [__] Bro
everybody you saw you see the people
around the thing yes yeah so like I'm
like I can't be racist because people
that are in the video are like what the
[__] I saw a guy right the video starts
with him like it's like the best like
drink in Delhi right I'm like oh what is
this the video starts off with this guy
grabbing an ice block with his bare
hands dirty as [__] and then smashing it
on the floor I'm like oh what's this for
grabs a chunk of the ice and throws it
to the drink and I'm like this is a
prank yeah takes his [__] Eagle Claw
which is his hand starts mixing it with
his hand ew right which is bad enough as
it is and I'm like okay cool whatever I
still might drink this if I'm in India I
don't want to be disrespectful dude it
doesn't get a ladle takes his [__]
Indian call ladles it with his hand and
starts doing this technique where he's
just dumping into up with his [__]
hand sometimes they get that they put
their hand in it and they they use the
other hand to squeeze it squeeze the
juice and then they're sweating so they
go like ah
and into the day and then you know how
sometimes there's that oh my God yeah
it's cream puffing but I honestly really
want to try because it looks so good
because they have a line there's a cream
puff thing but without the cream you
know what I'm talking about yeah yeah
yeah it's like a cup thing and they
scoop the juice yes I really want to try
that uh There's a comic uh Indian comic
and he said the restaurant that thing is
really good but the best one is is the
street one the juice one with their
hands scoop it with so the thing they
they will take it with the they'll touch
money right and their face so the money
touching and then dipping your hair
drops me off that's disgusting but
that's like a lot of the thing so like I
so you know for me like I got a lot of
Indian homes like there's a lot of
Sacramento people in Sacramento [__] to
Indian people it's like a lot of
childhood friends I'm like bro what the
[__] is this like would you eat this
they're like dude Indian people in India
don't like that [__] what I mean like
it's it's like in some of like the more
like not good areas is what I don't know
if this is true I've never been in here
but this is what they're telling me
because there's plenty of like Street
food vendors that actually do it a lot
cleaner but like some of the more
popular spots with a lot of locals is
like these spots he goes but if you go
to India specifically you eat that
you're going to be throwing up and
[__] all over the place 100 for sure
my friend said he was in bed for three
days because of that one yes yeah 100 he
goes so if you go to India just be
prepared if you're not eating stuff like
in well-known restaurants like what
they're not doing the sanitary thing at
all everybody's used to that bacteria
they're literally he's like he was the
one that told me about the drink scoping
thing and I looked it up on like YouTube
shorts and I saw a guy just go
yeah but like why like no spoons or and
[__] like what's going on no nothing
he's in the spoon to scratch his back
he's like all these tools for this like
I'll eat any street food whatever you
want I'll [__] eat that [__] right
that one I'm like this is kind of rough
that is very rough dude bro but there'll
be lines there's the people around them
that's the thing that throws me off yeah
but they look so good it looks so good
all the powder and the sauces that they
make with their hands Chutney all the
spices
and they don't give a [__] about heat
level either like I saw this guy making
like this uh it was China Masala right
he was making chana masala mixing it up
and I hit you [__] not it was like a
bowl of red chilies
come sit in there I'm like who the [__]
is gonna eat that yeah how yeah
all the way down the street holy [__]
she's down to eat it and he just grabs
Scoops it with his [__] hand so he
grabs the money just like you said yeah
grabs the [__] money puts it into
this little bowl and back in the curry
yeah back into the curry dumps it out
gets like the dried I think it was like
dried like uh fried shallots oh my God
dumps it on top there's like two like
like pratas puts it on top just hands it
off after he just wiped his sweat grab
the [__] money and oh my God and at
the same time I'm like that looks so so
good though but I don't want a diarrhea
I would love to eat it but without the
diarrhea can you just not touch the
money with your bare hand yeah yeah like
just not do that yeah or wipe your sweat
or anything important don't do this and
go oh my God yeah into the juice into
the juice
so for example like one of my friends I
was talking to his girlfriend and I was
telling her like yeah I think I like to
go to India she legit said why she goes
you would not survive if like if you
have a weak stomach like good luck
because she you know she goes back
because of family and stuff like that
and she's like dude every time I go back
I get [__] up like it's terrible damn
but then I got families I can stay at
home or whatever whatnot but like I just
know that like in the first few days my
stomach's gonna be Torah holy [__] I
don't think it's only for a few days I
don't think you're used to the thing
it's [__] months
months of absolutely death I just don't
understand that like it's like why why
do you do but she says that if you go to
like other there's like plenty of places
that are completely sanitary sure but
like the stuff that you see online it's
like
it's like the best but the worst of them
yeah
disgusting holy [__] dude uh not
disgusting delicious I am pro-india
[__] that means idiot uh
this wrap up this episode of Jesus spray
podcast I hope that people understood
that I meant this in all good health if
you are if you are Indian out there and
I guess I'm learning English from him
you can't just say it doesn't do bad
[__] and go I just meant this in a
positive name all good health dude and
all good health that's [__] gross bro
it's okay to say that's [__]
disgusting dude Indian food's great but
that's [__] gnarly bro this is
exactly what I meant to say it's naughty
as [__] and people know that I eat a lot
of [__] Indian food it's like one of
my favorite things to eat and I'm
talking about everything like if you eat
Indian food here in La you can find some
of the most delicious [__] ever buy new
market baby baby see you tomorrow hey yo
shout out to Bono they know that we've
been coming to them for [__] years
and hold that down if you guys ever want
to try good ass Indian food go to
[__] Banu out in Arcadia New Market
delicious lovely family there's a young
worker there that I've seen since he was
a little kid oh really working that
store holy [__] and now he's like a full
adult has mustaches pubes and everything
pubes crazy dude no way it smells nice
actually but genius spreading every
Sundays at 12 p.m and we will see you
all next time you can find Jason Cheney
at Jason Cheney on Instagram and
everything else that's
c-h-e-n-e-y remember to add that e and
you got Patrick dot T dot Riley check
them out they'll be doing shows out
there stand up making people giggle and
laugh all the [__] time and we will
see you all next time genius spray
Sundays at 12 p.m peace